[Applause]
hey everyone as here with another
episode of behind the screens g23 Expo
is coming this weekend and I'm here to
tell you everything you need to know and
what we can expect the e23 Expo is a
biannual convention that it's all things
Disney and since Marvel and Lucasfilm
fall under the Disney umbrella this
thing gets bigger and bigger every time
last Expo in 2015 was full of new
concept arts late announcements teasers
and a lot of guests surprises so Friday
morning day 1 kicks off with the Disney
Legends Awards and it might be a bit of
a cure jerker Carrie Fisher and Gary
Marshall will receive posthumous Awards
Stan Lee Oprah Winfrey and Mark Hamill
will also be honored and Mark could say
a few words about Carrie Friday
afternoon is the Pixar and animation
panel we know we're getting a look at
wreck-it Ralph - and Coco and we could
get more from gigantic Toy Story 4 and
we can expect some sort of new animation
project announcement to come out of this
one
now they do Saturday is the biggest day
of the weekend at 10:30 in the morning
it's a live action panel which could
include Star Wars Marvel and all of
those animated live-action remakes that
they're working on let's start with Star
Wars Episode 8 director Rian Johnson
tweeted he will be at d23 and he's
probably not just coming to hang out
expect some last Jedi news we just got a
teaser at Star Wars Celebration so we're
probably looking more along the lines of
a behind-the-scenes kind of reel now I
was certain this was going to be a big
event for the still untitled Han Solo
movie but with the original directors
Lord and Miller being replaced by Ron
Howard that's just seeming less likely
but this would be a good time to do a PR
revamp and get people to calm down about
the behind-the-scenes drama I'm
predicting we'll probably get one of
those hi from Seth sorry I couldn't make
it type videos from Ron's maybe before
we move on to Marvel's director Ava
Duvernay tweeted a wrinkle in time
teaser trailer will be revealed at d23
we could get some Mary Poppins Returns
action and of course there's those
Disney live-action remakes
we want is out next year The Lion King
casting news has been all over the web
and they're also currently casting
Aladdin okay now to marvel at the lassie
23 and 20
fifteen we got a lot of Marvel news this
year Marvel Studios has a 90 minute
panel at comic-con the following weekend
but that does not mean they're skipping
the expo ryan coogler and chadwick
boseman from black panther will be there
for signings on friday and Avengers
infinity war talent is having a signing
on Saturday 16 day as the panel so I'm
banking on some Avengers infinity war
news of course they're going to save
quite a bit for comic-con
speaking of comic-con come back next
week I'm going to break down what you
need to know and what we're going to see
from those dismal amount of movie panels
happening this year so like subscribe
comment and tweet me as always bye for
now
[Applause]
[Music]